hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca monster on a world again
today we're gonna be tackling the newest
monster monster on a world do nostril
and how to defeat
Orsola if you're new to this series we
take a look at the monsters weakness and
movesets discuss them and i show you
ways to dodges attacks and then we
follow it up with tips and my overall
thoughts at the end so let's get started
really quickly though I'm going to
explain how to get this monster to spawn
and basically I'll leave a timestamp but
if you already know how to do this and
want to get to the move set but
basically talk to the huntsman at Estero
he will give you a quest called the
Blazing Sun and then it's it's a HR 16
or higher to enter simply kill the T
Ostrow talk to him and then go back to
him go back to the smithy then he will
give you another quest which is also HR
16 which has you repel a loon Astra from
the special arena and then afterwards
once you do that you get an actual quest
to fight T Ostra and loon astra together
but going off the reporter head wings
and tail are her weak points with those
also being breakable or severable blunt
weapon users should stick to the head
sword users to the wings and range to
the tail for the maximum damage and her
weakest in terms of element is ice so if
you have an ice weapon when fighting her
you'll be doing lots of better damage
for the recommended lota i recommend
bringing absolutely everything mega max
and ancient potions as well as
Rocksteady mantle vitality mantle
temporal Mentos and fireproof Mantle's
would do great for this quest personally
I recommend the Rocksteady and fireproof
though but it's entirely up to you you
can also go with the armor skin and
diamond drug drinks which will help you
immensely throughout this fight put on
the move set her first move is this tail
whips use this very often I could be a
mistake but it does look like it has a
longer reach than T Ostra but I might
just be speculating either way she can
swing her tail once or twice so be very
careful on what she's doing but the
motion is always right to left then left
to right if she does it twice you can
either rush forward into her and attack
her underbelly or dodge back and wait
for her to finish there's also a
different variation in this move where
her body is covered in blue plastic
particles and then wear anything she
swipes the floor becomes lovest who
definitely do not want to run over those
next up as her flame blast T Ostra also
has the same move except to go shoulder
to shoulder wound Astro does a 180
degree spin going from right to - all
the way to her back as shown in the clip
the best place to be is her left armpit
from the left side of her body since
that's where the most safest place to be
fighting her is it's not like you're
going to never get hit from sitting here
but most moves won't hit you from
sitting nestled into her arm
next move is this quick flame spray
where she lights whatever is in front of
her and blue flames
that is her fastest move in her move set
and it's very difficult to dodge on
reaction but I found that either
Superman jumping or right in any
direction before the move works is
completely fine next is another flame
spray type except with a twist she
starts the move by spraying her side
then covers the area in more blue flames
she also has a chance to do this twice
if by chance you're knocked down from
this definitely stay down the
invincibility frames will keep you safe
for a bit until you get up causing you
to not get hit by half the move the next
move on this list is her head rush this
move is a very self-explanatory
basically she rushes forward very
quickly be careful when hitting her
because this move can cause you to take
some damage and it's a fair amount of it
to which if you're stuck in an animation
you could fly forward next up she also
has a grande pound where she simply just
leaps forward to pounce on you if you're
already running when this move goes off
just keep running in that direction
hopefully sideways and you will be out
of the area of this attack but if you're
standing still run really quickly and
then Superman jump and you should be
able to avoid it before it hits you next
move is her aerial moves and I will
showcase all three of the different
versions of this move number one is
where she sprays in a circular pattern
in front of her that has a lot of AoE
damage as you could tell by the clip the
best thing is to run and Superman jump
to avoid being hit or run out of the way
if you think you're safe
you usually do this move twice then
dive-bomb you but I have seen her do
this once and then dive mommying before
so definitely watch out for that the
second is her bond with T Ostra where
they both let off their supernovas
together as a couple they'll be there
will be an indicator on the side saying
that they bonded so watch out for that
and run as far away as possible
other than that Superman jump and prey
cuz that move what can one shot you and
then third is her supernova bomb just by
herself she flies into the air and then
drops down
causing a huge explosion with blue
flames everywhere here's the issue
though if you're caught within the
radius your health takes away super fast
it's still red health so you can
regenerates done but you will die if
that green bar hits the end after that
while your health takes away she sends
two other shockwaves just like in the
clip the best thing to do is Superman
jump unless you have space to run out of
the radius like in the clip I was pinned
against the wall and couldn't so I had
no other option while you Superman jump
your health bar stops ticking down but
you want to just time it just right so
you don't get hit by the shockwave after
the first major explosion one
the iPhone but I might be pushing this a
little bit as when I was testing I
counted about eight or nine seconds in
my head before the the second shock wave
went off after the big explosion so
jumping around seven or eight seconds
should be just fine if you want to count
that in your head that works just as
well I did it during testing and it
seemed to work just fine but like I said
I may be pushing in just a little bit
after I noticed watching the game play
back but that's entirely up to you
toaster is similar to loon astro of
course so others here should work the
same in fact it will be less blue flames
on the ground because elders here gets
rid of tio shows blast particles so it
should do the same with vanastra so
definitely try to have a weapon with a
high elder seal in it and as well don't
use flash pods on loon Astra according
to people on reddit not only is she not
affected by them but she will go
instantly into her supernova attack this
could just be dumb luck is that I have
yet to try this because I've never used
flash pods on her but just be very
careful with this on top of that you
also want to be bringing lots of cool
drinks because the the blue flames act
like lava so definitely chug those cool
drinks you don't take a lot of fire
damage and lastly is that you have to be
patient but also quick which sounds
really weird and doesn't really make
sense so let me try to explain that
patient in the way is that when she hits
you don't get up automatically and just
wait for her move to go and finish
through so you don't fall into a combo
and then get one shot or two shot and
the fast attacks because we with me
running with dual blades I was running
circles around her and it was super hard
for her to keep up it might be a little
bit difficult for heavier users like
hunting horns and hammers but for quick
quick attacks like sword and shield and
dual blades I was killing her just fine
but for my overall thoughts loon Astra
is definitely a very hard boss she's
very difficult and I think it's gonna
only get harder from here with future
monsters in the game which is a nice
turn but besides that she's honestly an
awesome monster to fight and it was very
difficult yet rewarding for the fight
for sure but that's gonna be the end of
the video today guys hopefully you guys
learned something new on how to defeat
Lou Nostra if you did please hit the
like button really does help me out
subscribe for free new I have tons of
other solo guides on the previous
monsters released like wolf 2 Roth devil
Joe all the other Elder Dragons as well
I also covered the news so if you want
to check my recent video on all the info
coming with glue nostra and all that
good stuff definitely check out that
video for all the info on all that stuff
and I cover the weekly event quests to
keep everybody up to date on it what
monsters do fight what event quests to
do and what ones give you the best
rewards so with that guys my two most
recent videos are going to be answer
if you guys wanna check that out that
hope you have a great rest your day and
peace out guys thank you for watching
the video